freedom convoy leaders claim nefarious
elements are planning to plant 2 000
stolen guns on protesters in ottawa to
discredit their movement after mounties
arrested 11 with cachet of firearms in
alberta convoy security chief danny
bulford made the allegation in a video
address late monday night claimed
nefarious elements planned to plant
firearms on demonstrators to discredit
them suggested the plot could be linked
to a truck filled with guns stolen in
ontario early sunday morning police say
that the truck was stolen as a crime of
opportunity by crooks who first tried
several other trucks but bulford thinks
it could be a dark plot to crack down
after trudeau's emergency declaration on
monday mounties seized 15 guns and
arrested 11 at a border blockade in kutz
alberta convoy leaders have declined to
address the arrests cutting off a press
conference when asked about them now i
don't know about all that uh false flag
stuff conspiracy stuff but i i will say
they're trying everything in their power
to shut this down
so what what do you guys think in terms
of plausibility for something like this
well i think from the very get-go um
what's been happening in canada
is just completely slanderous i mean
they've been calling them domestic
terrorists they've been calling them a
threat they've been calling them
insurrectionists it's like the same
buzzwords you see across the entire
board they did the same thing with j6
but this is is interesting because
there are legitimately peaceful people
in this protest but they still use these
words in these slander against them so
you have to ask yourself like you're
seeing their federal government
try so hard to slander who these people
really are i mean this this is a protest
with
bounce houses and inflatables and
there's children and people are just
demanding freedom and it's like not
violent but when you read something like
that it's really not that too far off to
be like
huh maybe something like that could be
going on because they're trying to
slander these people from the very
get-go you know well that's the problem
is that the slander is not sticking
right so at this point they have to make
these people look violent and i think
they would probably resort to any means
in order to do that yeah yeah i'm not
one for these kinds of conspiracies you
know show me show me the hard evidence
speculation
but the the challenge i suppose though
is
they've tried everything you know
they've they've tried claiming this
violence they've they've tried uh
they've tried
and anything to discredit
people that just want freedom
and that's what people people need to
like really
these are people demanding freedom they
want bodily autonomy right like they're
really not calling for anything else
other than we don't want to be
forced to take a jab right we want
freedom that's what we want and it's
crazy when you see them slander them as
like you know they're xenophobic when
you have like minorities or you have
immigrants that are truckers in canada
there's like there's a viral video of
these like indian guys and they're on
chairs or whatever they're bouncing and
playing music and everyone's dancing to
it it's like punjabi music yeah and
those those are the xenophobes those are
the racists but it's like it's these
same buzzwords over and over again but
i just i think people really need to ask
themselves like what you got to think
about it invertedly right if you're a
totalitarian psychopath those people are
terrorists in your eyes those people are
a problem those people do pose a threat
to you because if you are a totalitarian
psychopath anyone that's demanding
freedom in any way shape or form by
definition that's what they are in your
eyes and i think
a lot of canadians that are just kind of
in the hive mind right now shout out to
canada i love the canadians man but
there's there's a lot of people out
there that just eat up just like here in
the united states that eat up these lies
and they just believe them and they
gravitate towards them it's like well
though the government said so so it must
be true but
these
in a sense what i'm trying to say is
they do they they are a threat to the
regime they they are terrorists to the
regime because they are they pose a
threat to what they want to control if
you're the the uh
high life royalty atop your ivory tower
and the peasants have made their way in
heavens
yeah they're absolutely disruptive to
your way of life it's the lord's
mentality yeah
yes exactly and i think people need to
just just have you ever stopped to
consider the perspective of trudeau you
know he's sitting there minding his own
business with his team crumpets and
expensive champagnes when all of a
sudden these dirty poors are trying to
tell him what to do i mean
yeah these people absolutely are
terrorists going after him oh heavens
well yeah he's he's given us explicit
insight into how he views who he is
versus who the deplorables are because
that video that's recirculated lately of
him talking about how much he admires
china and the chinese government for
being able to i think he said be able to
turn their economy around on a dime
whatever that means and at the same time
in that video he also insults other
people for harper for wanting to be a
dictator and it's like what what project
much
right navigating one of the problems
i've got with the trucking combo right
now is i don't know what they want and
that's i'm communicating what are you
talking about they want to end the
vaccine mandates yeah but they want more
i just watched a video with the trucker
on national news uh somewhere i should
find on twitter it was like british news
or something and he was like so what
what do you want and the guy's like we
want you know we want we want he's like
you want to end the mac the van date the
vaccine made it he's like yeah we want
to end that what else do you want we
want freedom and i'm like what is that i
think he wants like an american
constitution but it's it's vague and so
they don't know how to give it if they
tell you ian we want to end the mandates
and you're expecting more than that and
what else
there's more but they want freedom and
like they want just want freedom like
what does that even mean and who are
they talking to i don't know man i'll
see if i can pull this off
the whole thing is about the vax
mandates right
and that's why they give you one
response but of course there's other
things they want to be respected they
want to be heard they're right they're
tired of the abuse i will say in
response to this guy coming out and
saying there's a potential false flag
smart
because they're going to smear him as
crazy they're going to say oh he's a
conspiracy theorist
well
better than letting them come with a big
truckload of guns
yeah the other part of what i was going
to say is i'm glad that this this story
is shouting out that there are leaders
involved because that was a problem with
occupy wall street is there no
leadership and so there was no unified
message and it dissipated i hope that
these leaders can put one together
yeah i think they do have very strong
leaders and i know that one of the
things that i was seeing from the press
was they were saying that the word
freedom has become supposedly a
right-wing talking point and i was like
there you go that's it that's how that's
that's how everything's shaking out
right now and that's how you know which
side of history you want to be on do you
want to be on the side of history that
says that freedom is a right-wing
talking point or do you actually care
about freedom and want people to make
their own choices 90 of truckers have
gotten vaccinated and it's not enough
for them they're still not allowing that
last 10 percent to live freely and to
work freely across the border freely
that's all they want they just don't
want the last 10 percent who feel like
they shouldn't have to take it to have
to take it that's basically what they
want that's their version of freedom i
was laughing this past weekend because
the counter protesters started coming
out you know they're running around with
their with their commie flags and all
that right and
you see some of these pro i posted this
on twitter the other last weekend
some of them are like throwing
themselves in front of trucks like into
oncoming traffic and it's like so you're
you're counter-protesting people
shutting down streets by shutting down
streets and throwing yourself in front
of oncoming traffic because you know
that just makes total sense it really
does in a very counter-intuitive a very
human ancient way they are advocating
for enslavement
they really are and that's in and that's
not the first time this has happened
like that does happen some sometimes in
certain cultures people advocate for
enslavement and they're literally doing
that and it's terrifying there were a
lot of people
that were defending ron desantis and
florida when they were passing this bill
the anti-writing law that makes it a
felony to block the roads in certain
circumstances and i said nah man you
can't that's why i'm not in favor of
that and we've had people come here and
argue and say
no there should be harsh penalties for
these people
when and and we always say this
you pass a law it will be used against
you now of course this is up in canada i
know not florida on the same thing but
uh if we want to have an american
trucker protest all of a sudden these
anti-riot laws come into play they're
gonna the left will be laughing and
being like oh you got you got what you
asked for here we go baby we're gonna
start rescuing resting all these guys on
felony charges
so
i think you've got to give room to
non-violent civil disobedience
that being said as for what's going on
in canada trudeau has lost the plot
war powers or emergency powers or
whatever he's doing over what bouncy
house
over inflatables but think about it
jacuzzis it's over people not wanting to
to serve not wanting to to participate
and so they're treating these people who
are just saying no to the system as if
they're violent extremists
it is so interesting to me because this
smacks of what america is trying to do
by painting all right wing people as a
form of terrorists because
one of the things that the emergency
powers in canada are supposed to do
they're supposed to protect canadians
from like actual threats to their
physical well-being and i think it was
ben shapiro i was listening to earlier
today made the point about how there
were riots in canada like last year not
to the extent there were in the us but
the black lives matter stuff was going
on in canada as well never shut that
down they never said we need emergency
powers for that that was actually a
threat to canadian businesses and to
commit canadian lives and well-beings
and they just didn't care this is
different this is political this is
deeply troubling to me a serious problem
with this not good yeah trudeau is uh
he seems sad he seems to worry about his
videos and it's just like yeah he's
talking with biden he has no idea how to
handle this and what he's doing now
isn't working yeah and that's
they're beyond desperate but what do
they do
what do you what do you do
you know he's like i'm not going to call
in the military i won't do it but
eventually
you know
if he moves in and uses force it'll only
make it worse so it's time you know he
and the rest of them realize they lost
it's over is this crackdown going to
work i mean after what going on three
weeks of this or two and a half or
whatever it is i'm really curious to
know if this crackdown will work i don't
know if it will or
define work
will it be a ccp style suppression of
people that are literally advocating for
freedom like tiananmen square exactly
tank's role that's exactly what i'm
thinking of will they will they uh move
into that realm of suppression and will
it work because it's worked overtime it
works but
it works to like get the trucks off the
road but whether or not it works to
preserve canadian you know freedom i i
don't think
i don't think that i don't think you can
blast your own citizens and expect to
stay in power in this day and age well
there's different canada there's
different arts of warfare right there's
obviously like military powers there's
physical war then there's monetary like
there's like economic war right there's
there's cyber warfare there's all types
of different ways you can go about
taking your enemy out and i think
they're clearly right now using
psychological warfare and they're
shutting down bank accounts they're
trying to use economic warfare by
drowning these people out
they already took to the streets and
tried to take their gas but i think
they're trying these different things
and and in my opinion i think they're
they're they're pretty serious things i
mean when you're trying to like shut
down someone's bank account because
they're asking for freedom that's a huge
problem to me that's just a serious in
my opinion
yeah i could see like what is these 24
year olds going to get their bank
account shut down for the rest of their
lives is that the plan justin no dude
without court orders
maybe this is just lining everybody up
for when the social credits uh social
crisis is thinking yeah this is just
prepping it all or you know uh
i was saying this story reminds me of
watchmen you know maybe in order for
them to uh for for the powerful elites
to enact their one world currencies or
whatever you know international free
trade agreements they want to get
through they need people to unify around
a villain
they they embody all the things they
don't want people to do
be jerks about it and then everyone
pulls back and doesn't does the opposite
so bitcoin for instance how do you get
mass adoption of a different currency
destroy the other one be a villain make
everyone think it's the safe haven quick
everybody run bitcoins the only way to
save you they're freezing our bank
accounts then all of a sudden everyone's
using a global digital
store of value that's trackable so they
used to hunt buffalo man they'd just
chase them off a cliff
scare them to run towards wherever they
thought was safe and it happened to be a
cliff that they were going off and then
what they would climb down and just pick
them up that's how
don't tell like uh hawks and like
falcons whatever they do for goats oh
maybe i don't know yeah like the
mountain goats will climb up and be
licking salt or something and then the
big bird just swoops in and hits it and
then just flips off the cliffs oh yeah
i've seen them do that that's wild yeah
that's one way to do it that's one way
to do it man you know this is this i
think i saw a trudeau
uh quote earlier today i think he was
saying and i'm paraphrasing someone
could find this they're listening
he said somewhere near to the near to
the extent of like not only are these
people that are the protesters like the
ones that are unlawful but those that
are supporting it as well
and like when you start to see stuff
like that that's when people need to
seriously wake up like i don't care what
your politics are but when you see
someone saying like okay those people
are wrong they should be silenced they
don't have the right to protest or shut
down a street whatever whatever but then
when you hear someone start to say you
can't even affiliate with those people
it's getting into some weird territory
and i don't think whatever your politics
are i think you should really take note
of that because just being affiliated
with someone and that's like breaking
the law
it's pretty interesting
all the phone carriers that are are
giving truckers phone access right like
how far does that go
it's always these vague statements like
what does that mean like what exactly
does that mean to you thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time